So there's now a growing republican movement
to impeach Donald Trump.
It's not huge, but it's there and it's getting
bigger.
It's bigger than it ever has been.
And one of the people sort of at the front
and center of this Republican Movement is
Republican Congressman Justin, a mash who
is saying what are actually pretty obvious
and uncontroversial things.
Although within the Republican Party there
are certainly rare things like, oh, Trump's
attorney general, William Barr misrepresented
the Mueller report.
Shocking.
And in a sense for a Republican to say it,
it's progress.
And Justin a mash is saying at any should
be applauded for that.
But the most notable thing about all of this
is that he's now saying straight up, Donald
Trump should be impeached.
He had a town hall in grand rapids, Michigan
yesterday, I believe.
And he got a standing ovation and at least
some small part of the Republican Party, at
least the people go into his town hall.
And clapping is increasingly behind the movement
to impeach the president of the United States.
Here's just a little bit of video from this
event.
I'm confident than if you read the volume
to you will be appalled at much of the conduct.
And um, and I was appalled by it.
And um, and that's why I stated what I stated.
That's why I came to that conclusion because
I think we can't go, we can't let conduct
like that go unchecked.
Congress has a duty to keep the president
in check.
And it is a difficult process for those who
are worried about, um, you know, Congress
intruding on the president's power is consistently,
it is a difficult process to remove someone
from office.
It's not easy.
So no one's suggesting that just because you
start some inquiry or process that a person
is removed from office.
Nonetheless, we have a job to do and I think
we owe it to the American people to uh, to
represent them, to ensure that the people
we have an office are doing the right thing,
are of good character, aren't violating the
public trust.
This is a Republican who saying this, it's
just one, but it's something and of course
Donald Trump immediately over the weekend
and continuing to just bash Justin a mash
personally with all sorts of insults tweeting
quote, never a fan of Justin and Matt, a total
lightweight who opposes me and some of our
great republican ideas and policies just for
the sake of getting his name out there through
controversy.
If he actually read the biased molar report
composed by 18 angry dems who hated Trump,
he would see that it was nevertheless strong
on no collusion and ultimately no obstruction.
Anyway, how do you obstruct when there is
no crime?
And in fact the crimes were committed by the
other side.
Justin is a loser who sadly plays right into
our opponents hands.
So bottom line, okay, one Republican member
of Congress says it's time to impeach.
It's a big deal in a sense, but it's also
not nearly a big enough deal to actually get
anything moving.
However, will Republican Senator Ben Sasse
join might, I don't know, Republican Senator
Mitt Romney join in Romney was recently asked
about Justin and mash saying it's time to
impeach.
Romney said it's courageous for him to say
it, but that he doesn't actually think impeachment
is warranted at this point in time.
There's the idea, maybe Mitt Romney could
be swayed on that.
Ben Sasse as a Republican senator from Nebraska
who's been a big critic of Donald Trump and
there are rumblings that may be SAS would
jump on board with calling for impeachment,
but it's very, very speculative at this point.
So, um, uh, we will just have to wait and
see as far as that goes.
Now as far as the mash is concerned, this
guy is no progressive hero, right?
It's really important to understand, okay,
he sees Trump for what Trump is, but a mash
is like an extremist, cartoonish, small government
guy.
Uh, his voting record is atrocious.
So this is not praise of Justin a mash beyond
just here's a guy who's a republican, but
he's not getting in line with the partisan
position on Trump period.
And that's it.
Right.
Is it likely that a mash is going to be the
start of, of landslide republican movement
towards impeachment?
No, it's not likely.
Is it possible?
A mash is the start of a small subgroup of
Republicans who by joining the remove Trump
side, maybe damaged Trump for 2020.
That's more reasonable.
And I think that's what we have to understand.
You know, let's, we have to have expectation
setting.
That's reasonable.
Are Republicans going to fully jump onboard
impeaching Trump?
No, they're, they're just not.
What we can hope for is that the Republican
impeached Trump Trump movement grows just
enough that it starts to kind of chip away
at Trump and become a thorn in his side, in
his quest for reelection in November of 2020
and maybe does some actual damage.